this is the theme humbly last Salaam
alaikum peace be unto you meeting your
hosting your watching the Deen show
we're here every week same time same
channel with some very exciting topics
and one of them is fornication the evils
of it you know sex is something that's
on the minds of many of the young men
and young ladies even the older men
older ladies but there's a way that the
creator of the heavens and the earth
told us and let us fulfill this desire
when you do it the wrong way
you got some bad consequences so we're
gonna be talking about some of the evil
effects some good that can come out from
doing it the right way but then also a
lot of evil can come out from doing it
the wrong way so we want to do it the
right way because death is a reality
it's approaching and we want to die in
the best state we want to die with our
Creator pleased with us and not him
displeased with us because we want to
get to Jinnah we want to get to paradise
so we're gonna get some good advice from
my friend and shake doctor shake will
lead by suni when we come back here in a
detials sit tight don't go nowhere this
is the Deen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Salaam aleikum peace be unto you but it
was salam o to love Allah care to shake
walk to the D show thank you for having
me again house came out of Mickey doing
doing good excellent excellent
here we speaks very highly of you
wonderful man how Allah we also we love
having him on the show we loved having
you on the show and all the other sheiks
and scholars who who helped to
contribute because we're trying to do
things that will benefit the world
I'm dill I just recently saw him in
Calgary he's doing very good you hear
eyes now in Calgary mashallah time is
short we know that you're the vice
president of Al Maghrib which we really
encourage people to if there's a seminar
in the locality their locality they
visit I also I had a chance to interview
it's coming up soon the program I did
with Muhammad Shareef how's he doing
very good he just went to Hodgins he's
doing very well I'm excellent
he's doing very good masha'Allah so we
recommend for people to visit these
classes that you teach and some of the
other sheiks Yasir Qadhi and sheikh be
Rajasa
yes are they doing very good very well
they're doing very well we give them a
salams - yes all right so you're also an
imam and this would be a spiritual
leader for the community in the clique
yeah clearly the Islamic center okay so
you give advice you're used to tackling
a lot of the issues that the community
is having and I'm sure this is a big one
this is a big one so the young man or
young woman comes to you says you know I
just can't get women off my mind I just
can't you know I can't let go of my
girlfriend I
can't you know I'll pray I'll do the
other things but it's just so difficult
shake it just so difficult to let it go
it's my weakness Allah will forgive me
you know it just make dua for me shake
how do you what advice do you give to
this young man first of all from the
last thought to Salim also Allah all
praise due to Allah in his praise and
blessings be upon our prophet muhammad
sallallahu salam his family his
companions and his followers until the
day of judgement and all the prophets
and messengers and their followers you
know idiots it's he's so unique the way
you put it it's not only today yes today
it's more than ever because all these
sexual messages and basically urged that
drive our sex drive very high you can
see it in the street and videos and DVDs
and your cell phones there's so many
messages out there just lead people to
heard that direction and to fall into
the haram the four buildings which is
for an occasion but this is the nature
of human being Allah created him with
and her with lust the the sexual lust
part of our nature as human and and it's
hard to resist some time a man came to
the prophet Muhammad SAW Solomon said ya
rasulallah
o prophets of o Messenger of Allah I'm
young man and I want you to give me a
permission to fornicate he wants he's
asking a messenger came to the messenger
he said would you give me permission to
fornicate he's basically saying just
hook me just hook me up give me some
leeway to do what I want to do yeah but
I mean uni give me a permission yeah
okay for me to do that because I'm a
young man and my loss was so strong and
I cannot control myself
yeah so the Prophet SAW seldom said and
this woman that you got to marry or to
fornicate with can you imagine this
happened to your sister or heater now I
think a little bit now then he said no I
wouldn't like my sister to forget it any
man would like your mother he said no I
wouldn't my mother too before he get in
any man he said so this is exactly the
same thing that woman that you want to
fornicate with her she
is a sister or a mother of someone she
might be a sister or a mother for
someone else
so as you don't want it to happen to
your sister and mother nobody would like
this to happen to their sisters and
mother and he said Oh young men Oh young
men if you cannot if you have a problem
and struggle with this issue fast
fasting because we need fast basically
and you fasting it means you prevent you
don't eat from the daytime all the way
to the night a drink or involve in any
sexual activity or thoughts so this is
will give you strength and he said it
will weak weak in your weakened your
sexual drive this fasting so this is a
solution he said in the beginning sorry
he said Oh young men who ever came Belov
getting married let him or her get
married so number one solution for this
dose of high sex drive or basically they
are he cannot control the sexual loss is
to get married you know there is nothing
more important than protecting your
religion it's more important than
anything else anything else once a young
lady came and she said I want to marry
this man I'm a foreigner student I came
from overseas and I'm studying medicine
here and I cannot protect myself and I
want to marry this man my father said I
cannot marry until basically I graduate
and I thought I told her father how can
you you don't care about her religion or
logic care about the degree what's the
degree will do her when she go in her
grave and basically they end up marrying
hamdulillah and to protect her herself
she doesn't want to do what is not right
so at Islam and all religions are
hamdullah have provide the natural
solution the right they clean the pure
solution for us which is basically go
ahead and get married and if you cannot
get married if you cannot get married
you can this does not justify for you to
go and to further Kate you have to
resist this temptation you have to
always remember that this is a great sin
a lost parrot a lie when he mentioned
the greatest sand that any human can do
he said
he said that the truth the believers are
the one alanine they will not worship
other than Allah with Allah and then
what I have to learn in a facility Haram
Allahu Alem aha and they will not kill
anyone he will not kill innocent so then
third while I asked noon and they were
not fornicate those are these three
things that Allah mention here identify
who is the believer and he said anyone
will commit one of these sins you'll
Donohue like that he will his punishment
will be multiplied in the day of
judgment will be multiplied so furn
occasion is a major sin that's a sin and
every religion in every religion and all
societies realized the dangers of
fornication how it would lead to the
weakness of the society where basically
we'll have children's from would like
where basically the highest number of
domestic abuse happen here in our
country to die that is because of those
who will have our relationships out of
marriage there is the domestic violence
the rate between the couple [ __ ]
married way lower than others where you
love an other than those who are
basically the relationship based on and
fornication or just girlfriend boyfriend
I know this in English a little bit in
America it's kind of different in the
West the word fornication mainly means
somebody will have a sexual activity
with an another partner
while one of them is married but in
Islam that's not how we identify how we
define fornication fornication is to
have sexual activity or intercourse with
a woman or with a man that he would the
other than your spouse period out of
marriage out America this is illicit
sexual activity that is prohibited in
Islam in Islam and every religion yeah
definitely okay we're gonna be right
back with more here on Adi show sit
tight go away go don't take the books
put the books in front of you and read
them read the Quran don't be a first
the question is about whether Muslims
are not good citizens the Constitution
defines what a good citizen is and the
preamble it says we the people of the
United States and form a more perfect
union establish justice ensure domestic
tranquility to be Muslim they can say
that is a good Muslim and most Muslims
can say that most Muslims will embrace
that most persons are good Americans you
and my daughter and me it's naturally
just idea and he created us to have a
good time you should have a good time
only without wives though Islam is the
fastest growing religion in the world
and most of the converts are women not
men they see that the rules of Islam
instead of constraining it the rules set
them free back here on the Deen show and
we are continued talking about
fornication illicit sexual activity
outside of marriage is a Class X felony
you know the felony with the Creator you
know you have certain laws yes and if
you break these laws they're classified
so major sin we classify as a class X
felony with the crater absolutely
absolutely a loss of power the Prophet
SAW solemn said lion is on he Nez knew
her movement the fornicator when he or
she fornicate they are not in a status
of faith they are they lose their faith
and if they repent that's where they
regain the fail again but somebody
fornicate that mean has no faith his
faith is so weak as if it's not exist as
if it's not exist so it's a sign of the
weakest time if that means your Eman is
in the lowest lowest level ever can be
rearranged it is a major sent the
Prophet assalam said Allah siddhis it
earlier the eve Allah Allah add a
boyhood fear on their sin their
punishment will be multiplied and will
stay in this punishment forever the
Prophet SAW solemn said I seen the
fornicators
our naked gathered in akin like a
container and a fire underneath of them
burning them and when he's loose those
people debris told him those this is the
punishment of the fornicator among your
Ummah in your nation those who will
commit the sin so no doubt it's a major
sin Allah Spinetta Allah hates it and
and curse those who doing it so anybody
involved and this earth of Allah sent
must repent to Allah Soprano a time and
get out quickly huh absolutely tell us
now for because we have a lot of not yet
Muslims and non-muslims who watch our
show so you know as they continue to
watch they see that is Salam the way of
life of all the messengers of God it
makes sense if they take it analytical
scientific approach they'll come to the
same conclusion as a 1.5 billion people
have across the globe that this is
indeed from the creator of the heavens
on earth and all the injunction is all
the beautiful things that we implement
are good for us and the things we stay
away from are things that are harmful
harmful for ourselves our family and
society and this is one of those things
illicit sexual intercourse outside of
marriage so tell us for the person whose
thinking he just so used to this casual
way of dating you know
test-driving and you know living with
the woman maybe four to three years
before you marry her and he says what's
the big deal all Muslim it's two
consenting adults we gotta say you know
there is a friend of mine he went to a
meeting for the school his son in public
school so they were discussing the issue
of sex education and basically it was a
discussion I don't know what was the
purpose of that discussion but what the
teacher over there she basically gave
them a piece of paper and basically give
one of them piece of paper and they went
to eat so this brother because it has
some kind of food that he's not familiar
with he didn't eat it so he didn't
participate with them so after they came
back that teacher asked okay who had
this paper he said yes he said did who
did you shake hand with when you're
socializing
the food he said I did so he said
basically and she was talking about how
sex out of marriage can transfer these
diseased sexual terms and disease can
spread so quickly and she said by you
contacting this person this person can
tag this person said this is again
everywhere so he'll talk about the
importance of knowing some information
about these issues and so that Muslim
brother strike him he said hello
I didn't shake any hands with any one of
these guys I didn't put them participate
in this so I didn't get affected Wow and
he said do you know why because I choose
the methods of absence I I stayed away
from it that's why I'm protected so the
prophets are silent a little bit not I
said any nation in the nation will
basically commit zina adultery or
homosexuality or anything like that from
this nature and they will practice it
openly without shame being shamed of it
the process of solemn said Allah will
punish them by diseases that it was
never exist in the nations before them
and all these sexual transmitted disease
that we discovered to die and we
suffering from all this yeah any
hundreds of thousands of people died
unfortunately and my heart goes for
those who died from AIDS from these
diseases a lot of them even innocents
like kids and stuff like that it is
because of what because of what what the
transmission sexual disease in United
States what's the statistic today talk
about pregnancy a teenager pregnancy
talk about this children's out of
wedlock what's the percentage very high
and all these diseases that you see
psychologically and physically it is
because people practice adultery people
practice for the fornicator they
basically have illicit sex outside of
marriage and that's punishment but if
you obey Allah and you obey his law
you'll be protected from this and no
need to spend millions and millions of
dollars and resources and people die and
and in all these years in this
because people feel folders are an
illegal way now you see that I mean
Islam is the natural way everything
you're doing it brings you peace and
happiness and it makes sense that you
fulfill this desire within marriage
which send some confines that are good
for you there's structure here and that
protects yourself your family and
society but I mean if you do it like
just your own way and you do it how you
know this this way that's not pleasing
to the crater all you got to do is turn
on Jerry Springer or Montel and you see
a 10 year olds 11 year olds 12 year olds
they're following the parents bad
examples probably and you see what's
happy the evil effects yeah fornication
isn't it it's actually disgusting when
you just think about it you know when
you just fornicate and you just you know
just about fulfilling my desires with
this woman or without or hiring a
prostitute just to fulfill my desires
and move on and my hey you know the way
I look to my sister the way I look at my
brother is way more respectful than that
more just go and release myself in her
and move it's not like a public bathroom
yes go delete your solo and go this is
so disgusting I think this is wrong and
absolutely I wouldn't like this to
happen to my family to myself and I
would say there is the purity in
marriage the happiness in marriage
security is America is not outside the
marriage Islam looking to build a strong
Society a strong Society not following
not fulfilling their desires in Haram
Haram why to be slave to your desire I'm
gonna be a little tough here please bear
with me some people you know it was a
family show but isn't it easy to be a
dog or a hole but it's different to be
on a way that's disciplined a way that
you restrain yourself in those desires
that are coming out it takes a little
bit of effort not to curse it takes a
little bit of effort to hold back when
you're doing your angry and to be a
better character it's easy to just let
loose isn't it absolutely absolutely and
that's why that's what differentiate us
from animals animals they just go with
anyone you know that's we're not like
that we're human beings
Allah honors us and
give us the strength to control our
desire yeah so now we are almost out of
time we'll take one break and we'll come
back and wrap it up all right thank you
we'll be right back here Nadine show
what can you put your dream home and
you've got your dream car but you're
gonna get old and things are gonna
happen to you in your life and then what
have you got at the end of the day is an
empty dream that has no real foundation
we are gonna dine and we're gonna meet
our Lord and he is going to judge us it
becomes an obligation for each single
human being to find out what the Quran
is Islam is telling us to stay away from
things which are bad for your person in
bed for the society it's killing of
innocent human beings human life is
precious and if we're gonna worship
something I figured I might as well
worship the Creator instead of any of
the creations now in upon investigating
the religions I remember finding out the
meaning of what Islam is what Muslim is
those who surrender their self to God is
a Muslim those who surrender submit to
God God's will that is Islam was pure it
was just you just pray to God you create
[Music]
I am NOT a Jew stand alone if you live
by my side I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone I
am Not Afraid
[Music]
back here on the Dean show with dr.
shake will lead bassoon Ian we tell
mother evil consequences of fornication
Class X felony we established that and
you open yourself up to the punishment
of the creator of the heavens and earth
and this is something that you need to
repent for right away but tell us those
young youth okay sisters in hijab and
and and their dressing modestly and the
brothers also trying to lower their gaze
but now they feel the heats coming on
you know the traction said obsolete jet
they want to get married they do we want
to do it right but I've got the parents
you know they're there and let's say the
last year of of high school you know
they're at the age legal age that they'd
get married with the parents now they
want them to get the master's degree you
know the diploma and they're like
fighting their kids honest what if eyes
do you have for the parents first of all
tell the parents that if you have a son
or daughter that can pair the
responsibility of getting married
encourage them to get married I'm in
favorite of marrying and in early ages
as long as they can pair the consequence
of marriage they can take the
responsibility for marriage that's
beautiful thing to do if you can they'll
help them please do I also would like to
say that I lost panna cotta you know we
know that not everybody can get married
and people exposed to sexual desire
before even get the legal age for
getting married yeah and they have this
desire what's the solution what's the
solution first of all I love what one of
the Muslim scholars said which is named
it was a demon was a human law he said
this last is like fire the more you add
to it it will not go away it will get
bigger and bigger a lot of people think
by fulfilling their desire it will come
down I want to tell you that's not true
it will the fire will became bigger and
bigger and bigger if you could make it
one time you're not gonna just come down
you're gonna need more it's never be
happy never be severed away it will be
stronger like adding more wood to the
fire more guests to the fire the fire
will became bigger it will never go away
you know you're not gonna put it out by
doing and fulfilling the desire the only
way to card this desire to put it out
this fire it's not to add any more wood
stirred not gas to it it's me to stop to
avoid this
we're lost Canada and I said when our
table was Xena he didn't say don't for
negate he said don't come closer to
fornication Unni don't do anything can
lead to fornication that's why in Islam
woman been asked to dress modestly so it
will not send these sexual signals
for those who have sick heart or mind
thinking sexually about their opposite
gender so that's why she dressed modesty
the islam said don't be with a woman
alone in one place in one room in a
hotel room or in in a clothes basic in
an apartment you and her alone if she's
not related to you why because you might
that might happen between you guys
between them
what is Haram like he fallen fornication
or sexual activity take place we're not
saying everybody will do that but Aslam
close the door don't get take a chance
Islam said you're not allowed to touch a
woman while with lust
you're not allowed to look at woman with
desire and the moment you feel that
you're looking at her and you are
sexually thinking about her sexually you
have to to move your lower your gaze if
you touch a woman and there is a desire
and this touch you're not allowed to do
to do so also and Islam told us that
we're not allowed to listen or to do
what can drive our sexual drive very
high while we cannot contain it and they
not married you're single what would he
do by for example like looking at
pornography is looking at what their
pictures magazines movies that come out
basically raise my sexual drive very
hard and then what
from the beginning Islam don't do that
don't look at this so protect you it
keeps you very far away from what is
there where is the Zener is and this is
one aspect of it also the other part of
it
Alyce LOM asked us to be pure always to
remember Allah spirit on to look at our
sister or brothers and brothers and
sisters we don't look at them at
actual objects also it ordered us
basically to fast to pray to to keep our
so busy with things that it will
occupied our mind and and so forth so
you will not be thinking about this and
you will have control over your sexual
drive so eliminate all those promiscuity
things of promiscuity on the television
movies they might get your sex drive up
eliminate this no pornography no self
pleasure
none of this stuff yes this is this is
only add to it it's not going to
complain it absolutely yeah okay and I
think this is so powerful lowering the
gaze because yes if it goes from here to
the heart and then somewhere I'll get
some trouble absolutely so this is
powerful isn't it it is it is that's why
I lost my Allah and he talked about
adultery and the punishment of those who
commit adultery and fornication after
that he said I order the believer male
and females to lower their gaze mm-hmm
so he ordered them because that would
lead to those most of the time yes okay
so last look last point tell us right
now for that person male or female they
might have lived a life he might have
lived a life of a dog she might have
lived the life of a you know a a I said
it earlier I'm just feel timid okay you
know yeah fulfilling their desires as a
whole let's say and she don't want to be
in that state anymore and she feels the
heaviness the burden of the sin is there
any hope for him if they leave it right
now they repent and change their way
what advice do you have for me
first of all outside cut it off
completely with a Pinto a Lost Planet
Allah repent to Allah and ask him to
forgive you and I guarantee you you will
not find anything but an open arm from
your Lord welcoming you back and
forgiving you and helping you and aiding
you and will transfer your scent good to
a reward after it will be forgiven and
it will be erased from your bay a book
of records and you will meet him pure
and clean inshallah God don't give up
and the ever in the last month or so
that's why Allah after he mentioned
these three
since that I said in the beginning that
the [ __ ] associating other with Allah
and killing an innocent Saul and
fornicating he said after that that
those who repent to me and thus which
they start doing good Allah promised
them that he would reward them and he
will be pleased with them so don't ever
give up the hope and a loss potala and I
promise you you enough you will find
nothing less than a God whose welcoming
you a lord that he will help you and aid
you to start a new clean life this is
very exciting to know to know thank you
for the great advice may God Almighty
Allah reward you we look forward to
having you back in shuttle I think
you're very much against for some more
shows thank you very much you Sonic
alaikum Salaam
and thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the D show some great and
wonderful advice from our share if
you're involved in this turn your life
around stop reflect reflect about the
beautiful things that the Creator that
observer has given you work to please
him remember the home that you're going
to be in six feet under and you want to
go in that hole with good deeds racked
up not bad deeds and this is a Class X
felony with the creator of the heavens
on earth it's a major sin it's a major
law break you don't want to be in that
state in the grave and this follows you
with you stop this change those bad
deeds into good deeds repent and he's
the most loving the most merciful to
welcome you with open arms
and continue to come back here to the
Deen show until next time peace be unto
you in every individual there comes a
day where they need to take a second
just to contemplate about life
man I wonder why am i living it just the
time I'm breathing my days the crease
and God please hear me give me the
reason why you brought me in this life
the truth I wanted to get so depressed
I'm stressed no control of my soul like
a hole in my chest can't sleep at night
so I drop her to the open watch the
stores while I listen to the ocean